Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous etactivez la petite cloche !
Bonjour à toutes les Épicurieuses
et tous les Épicurieux.
Aujourd'hui c'est mercredi.
Le mercredi c'est un petit peu notre cour de récréation
puisque jeréponds à vos questions.
On commence par Cedrick Boucher sur Youtube :
« Dis Jamy,
est-ce que tu pensespouvoir traiter
certaines expressions québécoises dans tes vidéos
" pourquoi on dit " ? »
Eh bien c'estune excellente idée !
J'adorerais cet exercice.
Alors des expressions québécoises
mais pas uniquement hein !
Des expressions francophones
quelque soit
leurs origines.
Par conséquent,
eh bien,
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer ces expressions
en commentaires de cette vidéo
et puis
si vousavez aussi l'explication,
eh bien,
donnez-la moi.
Je serai
« aux petits oiseaux »
comme on ditau Québec.
Une question de chose951 sur Twitter :
« Dis Jamy,
survivrait-on si une météorite de lamême taille,
que celle qui a tuée les dinosaures,
s'abattait sur Terre ? »
Alors pour toutes celles etceux
qui ont peur que le ciel leur tombe sur la tête,
sachez que j'ai fait une petite vidéo sur
ce sujet pendant le premier confinement.
Vous pouvez la retrouver sur Youtube.
Elle a été postée à la finavril 2020.
Je l'ai réalisé au moment du passage
de l'astéroïde 1998 OR2.
Pour mémoire,
l'astéroïdequi s'est abattu sur Terre
il y a 66 millions d'années,
qui a provoqué
la disparition desdinosaures,
mesurait entre 10 et 12 km.
S'il a eu un tel effet
c'est aussi parce qu'il est tombéà un endroit très particulier.
Là où il y avait des réserves de pétrole naturel
ce qui a
amplifié
les effets de la collision.
Par conséquent,
si un astéroïde de la même taille
retombait sur Terreaujourd'hui
mais à un autre endroit,
évidemment
il provoquerait d'importants dégâts.
Mais
pas sûr
qu'il fasse disparaître autant d'espèces que celui
qui est tombé sur Terre il y a 66 millionsd'années.
En tous cas je l'espère
parce que je n'ai pas envie de terminer comme les dinosaures.
« Dis Jamy,
fais-tu de la musique ? »
C'est une question d'I.L.L.L.U.S.I.O.N.S
Eh bien malheureusement,
non !
Je ne fais pas de musique mais je ne désespère pas.
Je rêve de jouer un jour
de la clarinette.
C'est pas du pipeau !
Une question de Paul sur Twitter.
« Dis Jamy,
si un hélicoptère utilisait un
moteur entièrement électrique,
est-ce qu'il ferait encore beaucoup de bruit ? »
Alors il ferait sûrementmoins de bruit
mais il ne serait pas totalement silencieux.
En effet le frottement de l'air
sur les pales,
des pales qui tournent très vite,
générerait également du bruit.
C'est pas un hasard
si onéloigne les éoliennes des habitations
qui tournent moins vite que les pales d'un hélicoptère.
Entendons-nous bien !
« Dis Jamy,
pourrais-tu participer à notre exposé ? »
Alors vous êtes trèsnombreux
à me faire ce genre de demandes.
Beaucoup trop nombreux même !
Si je répondais à toutes vos
demandes, eh bien
je n'aurais plus le temps de faire autre chose :
plus le temps de répondre à cette FAQ,
detourner des vidéos avec la petite caméra,
d'écrire des livres,
de fabriquer des « le Monde de Jamy ».
En revanche,
sachez que
la plupart des thèmes sur lesquels vous travaillez
ont été abordés dans différentes émissions.
Dans les « C'est pas sorcier »
avec Fred et Sabine.
Dans « IncroyableExpérience ».
Dans « le Monde de Jamy ».
Dans les vidéos qui sont disponibles
sur ma chaîne Youtube.
Etpuis enfin,
je voulais vous confier quelque chose.
Vous savez,
j'aime beaucoup expliquer
mais j'aimesurtout me poser des questions
et aller chercher des réponses.
Et quand on trouve la réponse
dans un livre,
sur un site internet
ou auprès d'un expert,
eh bien là,
on éprouve une grande joie!
Faites l'essai
et vous m'en direz des nouvelles !